hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i'm
a property investor and a property
youtuber and guess who's filming this
video right now behind the camera is
absolutely nobody no one's behind the
camera right now because my videographer
you know what every time i hire a
videographer within three months
they become financially free in property
by watching my videos
and then quit so i figured you know what
literally that's happened so many times
i need to find someone that's already
financially free off the back of the
training and hire them and that is kerry
so kerry thank you so much for coming on
winners on wednesday thank you for
having me it's very unusual for me to be
this side of the camera because you
normally edit winners on a wednesday and
film and do everything yeah there is
literally no one no you'll be you're
probably i think it's the ninth the
ninth videographer that we've had over
the five six years and um you know
obviously we've got a few videographers
still amelia and some of the guys and
i want you i want to i want you to sort
of tell me firstly how and when did you
apply to become a videographer and then
we're going to talk through your journey
of financial freedom and how you've done
it yeah so i saw that you were doing a
massive social media
boost on
i think it was in december last year and
i just saw that post and i don't know
what it is but i was like i am getting
that job like i i'm doing everything to
get that job because
it just for me it ticked all the boxes
like i was already doing property i saw
i've seen you in person i'd been at your
courses i knew that we got on as well
and i think that's really important for
you and i was just like that's mine yeah
but why did you want to get a job well
we'll maybe get to that we'll maybe get
to that
but
your journey what's your back story what
does kerry do what did kerry used to do
what's your kind of background so i used
to work i was like a trained actress and
i worked in film and i did lots of
children entertainment like you did um
and can do balloon tricks as well like
you can and um and then covered here and
then literally like my whole life turned
upside down overnight and i had no work
like it was just my bookings were all
like i had nothing i had the money in my
bank account and that was it to last me
the whole of covered which no one knew
how long it's going to last
um and i just thought i don't like this
i was like i don't i don't want this to
ever hap i don't ever want to be in this
situation again like i've paid so much
money for my training and i do not feel
secure in my industry like i'm always
waiting for the phone to ring like i'm
just i need something else and i was
looking at going into service
accommodation beforehand i think i seen
an advert on on instagram and i looked
into it and i thought okay i can
definitely fit that around my life
and then um i can't remember when it was
i think obviously then covered happened
and then i just thought all right i need
to do this i was watching all your free
videos like maybe service accommodation
isn't the best time right now in march
2020 to get into it but watch this space
then as soon as it educated myself
throughout the whole of lockdown just
from your free stuff
and then july 2020 came and i just like
secured my first deal got straight in
there and to be honest uh because i
don't feel like i had the right training
or experience i completely mucked it up
it wasn't systemized there was like
double bookings
um i was having literal panic attacks
i'm not even joking like i was
i
like hyperventilated yeah one day um
because i just was so overwhelmed i
think from like doing nothing for four
months then all of a sudden having all
this responsibility yeah getting people
in like the cleaner like i was cleaning
the place myself because my cleaners it
was just a nightmare like
so unfortunately the landlord i won't go
into the details but the landlord did
ask for it back in the end did you have
the right contract or not no not at all
so he just
so basically kind of like binge watched
the youtube channel yeah got enough
information to do it but not enough
training to do it properly
i think this is a business right it's a
business and it's like any business if
you want to be an actress you said you
went to training and you learned how to
be an actress yeah if you want to be um
an electrician or a doctor or anything
you have to go and get formal education
yep um so at what point did you realize
forget this i'm done i'm actually gonna
go on the courses i
pretty much well i was so like knees
deep at the time i couldn't see it it
was only until i got out of it i thought
i need to educate myself now like i
can't be making these mistakes again
like i'm not using the right channel
managers i'm not
it's just an absolute
chit show
and then so i came back once i'd lost
the property um i thought there were
elements of that i loved and i really
like it and i want to do this properly
because i think for a lot of people that
would be enough to like get running for
the hills like there's no way but you'd
seen the the good aspect but you just
didn't have the the right education to
run it properly also i was just doing it
all by myself and i think that's why i
was having the panic attack because i
felt so overwhelmed like i felt so alone
i felt like an island yeah and then i
thought okay i'm gonna invest in some
training and i think we still went at
the live events at this point i'd like
already had one and lost one like before
you were even back on stage and then um
i thought okay let's let's do this
properly like i definitely love samuel's
training i like i'm gonna invest in it
and i think it was over you know covered
period when you were doing the online
stuff but paid for
and just i just binge watched the whole
thing in like i think maybe one or two
sittings and then
bam i got one pretty much straight away
afterwards on the same um
residential area and it was all very
legal it was all good it was i didn't
you know mess anything up and um it was
all by the book and then came along to
your uh december uh went to rent
revolution and that's like i just
changed everything for me what was your
what was your first successful deal
after the training so my first proper
deal um after the training i secured
this amazing
um one bed with the most stunning
terrace um it's like a dream where is it
in in wedding um
and yep the landlord was just a bit done
he just wanted like a four-year deal and
he wanted just me to take over a bit
desperate a little bit desperate i'd say
yeah i i think i found i sought after a
desperate landlord where did you find
him where did you find them um so i just
was went through my estate agent i'd
used
like previously who'd i actually was a
friend so i kind of had a little bit of
an in in there i was letting them know
that i am thinking of doing this yeah um
if anything comes up you know let me
know
my mum is also a property manager so i
had her as a reference so i was quite
lucky in that way and my mum has helped
me so much and um she's really really in
the know of property um but i just again
wasn't asking for help enough in the
early days i thought you're really gonna
do this on my own you know and the thing
is because you had the estate agent
friend yeah you almost had the even
without the training you were able to
get deals but it's just about to be able
to systemize it properly exactly and
making sure that it's all synchronized
and it's all clockwork yeah and you know
what i'm so glad i didn't use my friend
for the first one because i just messed
it up and like she wouldn't have trusted
me again to you know yeah get another
deal so then i felt good i felt like
ready um i furnished it properly like
even though i was furnishing the other
one like they were like why have we got
no teaspoons i was thinking
put put teaspoons in there like little
tiny things that you go through in such
detail
i hadn't thought of and just little
things like putting the wi-fi in a in a
good place so that they're not
constantly messaging you and like it
just wasn't properly systemized
basically um and then yeah found this
amazing deal and i just got addicted to
it so i just
was just flat out then using the contact
i had um like i said my mum is a
property manager so she knows landlords
as well in the reading area um she knew
of another landlord in the reading town
center that was just in singapore had
nothing to do with the property needed a
little bit of a renovation so i said why
don't i project manage the renovation
then come get it on a company let so you
don't have to worry about anything you
just show me what you want we'll source
it me and my mom and we'll just renovate
the whole flat for you um and she said
okay if you do that then this is the
rent and it's like nothing how much do
you pay rent for that property uh so
that was my second one it's 690. 690
pounds
town center and it's massive beautiful
high ceilings and how much do you get
per night okay
over reading festival i get like 350 a
night wow but that's obviously once a
year um i average
60 67 to sort of 77 in that in that
field so what about the first property
how much do you pay the landlord that
one's a little bit more but i get a lot
more at night so that one's 100 sorry a
thousand and 95
but
it's stunning it's like the penthouse
it's got like a nice terrace which still
is not bad it's a one bed and obviously
i've got a sofa bed in there so we can
sleep up to four
um so
yeah i get
about the same profit from each you did
say this once you're like for some
reason you always get around the 750
mark yeah and it's it's pretty much spot
on um
give or take depending on festival i
mean over
over the reading festival we can i make
750 profit in that weekend per property
and right now you've got three i've got
three up and running so then i got
another one because then i just thought
right okay my thing at the time was i
just want one a year i just wanted to
like and then i watched another video
and you were like let's make your one
year plan like uh one year one year plan
like a one month goal so yeah right
and then the landlords i i don't have
any problems with the landlord but there
was just something in me that just
wanted to own my next one like i don't
know why i was just like i really really
want to own my next one now
um so then i just used all the rent to
rent money i was getting i just stashed
it all so essentially it wasn't my money
but i just wanted to like use my own
money for my first property and then
yeah and then i used all the money and
then i got an investor and i've just
recently literally last thursday
completed on my first product yay
so you're a homeowner now i'm kind of a
baby the house that you bought yep you
basically used a little bit of
investment yep that you managed to
borrow yeah from an investor yep and you
also used the money that you'd made from
rent to rent yes put that together yeah
bank what did you buy i bought another
one bed
you're obsessed with this i love one is
it wedding it's in reading yeah um it's
like opposite the hospital it's the best
location
put it this way i put it on airbnb with
the shocking photos that i bought it
with i've i've renovated it as well in
like three days i've got the photos um
that i've just done like very very
minimal changes but they've made such a
dramatic impact but i put on airbnb the
basic photos that i bought the property
with and it's already booked up from
today till mid july wow
so what should we call this video how
rental rents made me a homeowner yeah i
like that that's a good one because it
literally has like it
if i didn't do the rent to rent my money
that i was earning
through
because just before i started working
for you i was working for a law firm
doing their videography it was really
really unhappy to be honest um but it
was just to get through covid
literally and i knew at that point i
needed some sort of income to get a
mortgage like consistent be an employee
basically
um
so
i just did that to get through coverd
and all my wages
were just going on my living expenses
like i had nothing so if i didn't have
these rent to rent i wouldn't have been
able to save a penny like it would have
just
sourced they were just about funded my
life with no real luxuries like no
holidays
no
you know yeah at the rental rent
revolution you
won a hundred pound there yeah yeah i
did because you found the best deal you
actually gave me 200 because you gave us
more because you were so impressed yeah
so you made 200 pounds yeah and that
program was one pound so you invested a
pound i made 200 pounds literally that
day and
yeah i i my family were down i hadn't
really seen them and i was like
i love you guys
but i'm gonna go get rich
i'm gonna go learn how to make some
money another interesting thing is as
well it's so obvious that you properly
believe in
the the training and everything that
you're doing because not only did you
apply for a job and get accepted but you
just yesterday persuaded your brother to
join the academy yeah i did so i brought
him along um didn't take much much
persuasion i think he just came along
and he was absolutely
just
blown away by you and your training and
what you do and your education that you
give away for free she was like this
guy's giving this for free like
what am i going to learn because he
actually owns an essay as well in
reading
um
i think me yeah me my brother and my mum
we've all got a little like less essays
as our safe haven like we all we all do
it are you competitive or do you work
together we all work together because if
they can't host one guest we do and
we've got pretty much a hundred percent
occupancy rate pretty wow
give or take maybe one or two nights so
reading is the area oh it seems to be we
get loads of relocators and we what's
amazing about our areas because it's
it's busy but it's not popping like it
hasn't got like the busy nightlife like
birmingham cardiff and manchester is you
get loads of relocators that are working
there with their families yeah so
and they stay there for like three
months i know you didn't just get a
booking for like two three months this
morning literally this morning it was
like two yeah mid july
yeah and obviously they get a bit of a
discount but still i'd much rather that
then organize all the clubs they'll pay
you like 60 pounds a night or something
67 60 years on the night but then you'll
be paying the landlord
690. yep you haven't got any cleaners
because they're just there all the time
they're there all the time so what's
that what's 67 if they're paying you 67.
67 pounds and now my mortgage down my
mortgage is 500 so it's not much times
31 that's over two grand yep
yep and you've not got up high cleaners
nope
nice bit of profit yeah i'm up well the
bills are just about to soar but even
still still too decent it's still
definitely worth doing but when the
bills saw what will happen is rents and
everything exactly so i'll just put my
prices up yeah exactly so yeah the the
big one with the terrorist doesn't do as
well um
i don't know why it just
i i get again i get people staying in
there for a long long time yeah
but
the bills are a little bit more the
council tax is a bit more so that does
make a difference but
roughly i get about yeah about 750 per
pound so what was the rent to rent
revolution like then obviously this
program is just a free program yeah it
costs a pound yeah what was that like
your first time changed everything for
me i don't know i'd already been doing
service accommodation already invested
in your programs online
um there was just something about that
day that i just like went there met
networked with like-minded people i
think that was the big thing for me
um
because i'm so used to people being like
oh airbnb is this being so negative and
i was just in a room with like over like
200 people i think was were at that
event and i just thought
how can i get in this environment i need
to be around this all the time yeah and
i think the next week you posted
something that i'm skilled in that you
needed and i was like
that's mine like i need to somehow
you know and i i think i said in my
application i was like i can't i just
want to do this job to give back to
samuel i've i've been to film school i
know how to work cameras on how to do i
know what to do but i just want this job
to give give something back because i've
got so much education from you and we
had a lot of positive comments about the
youtube channel after you came on people
saying oh level it up on that i love it
yeah i know it's just always lovely to
hear so why would you not because
obviously you've got pretty much a
full-time role really as a videographer
you head up single-handedly pretty much
head up the youtube channel
why would you do that obviously you're
paid but when you could just do property
only again i think
um no man is an island and i definitely
learned that the first time and i
struggled so much and just being even on
the trial i was like these guys are
i just got honest with everyone so well
and i just felt like they were my my
people and i feel like there's you've
got like you've created like a mini
family within the academy and the team
and i just thought i like absolutely
love it here and i'm doing something i
love i love videos i love creating
videos and i love editing i love
property
and i just thought it just ticks
everything in one i love the variety as
well so like when we're on the road and
then yeah i'll be like in my room for
like three days straight and then we'll
like be here from my perspective the
reason why i wanted to hire you
obviously the main reason was because
you're a brilliant videographer and we
got on wow great work every great work
ethic but also because you'd already
become financially free in property i
kept hiring people and then they'd
become financially free and then they'd
quit so i thought man it's quite
annoying so i thought if i take you on
at least you've already come to the
train and you've already invested the
trade so you're not going to be just
picking my brands constantly because you
already know everything exactly you've
already got properties it was like i
said it was for me it was just i was
like i just want to give back to this
company that essentially changed my life
and if i can help other people as well
yeah because even at the training
programs people are coming up to me and
i can advise them yeah comfortably and
it feels great like i totally understand
why you do this because i can like sit
there and people come up to me and i i
feel great and i'm sharing the
information that obviously i learnt and
if you'd have just kept that to yourself
yeah you know i wouldn't be in the
position i'm in now so
again it's just like paying it forward
and so we appreciate that hardest thing
about property yo
i'd say the hardest thing about airbnb
because obviously i'm not that's the
only thing i do
is
being on call 24 7. so that would be my
next step is probably getting
a property manager to take that off me
because i've had calls at three in the
morning we're locked out can you break
the keys yeah i'd say that's probably
the hardest having to be on call all the
time yeah is for me
i'd say
it's a i don't i don't know if it's even
hard it's it's a challenging thing and
it just makes you realize how
responsible you are
for me whereas before i had no
responsibilities i was just getting the
calls going to jobs and then just like
getting on with my life whereas i always
have to be make sure my phone's near me
so how do you systemize that thing
because of course there's a lot of a lot
of the business that you systemize in
terms of the bookings the cleaners yep
but if a guest has got a problem you may
have to reach out to someone yep and at
the moment that person's you yeah
and how do you systemize that i suppose
like you advise is to write a manual of
like your brain um if someone wants to
come in and property manage they'd have
to i think be local you can't i don't
think you could do virtual um virtual
assistants in this
for
in my opinion anyway
um but yeah i think you just have to
like get everything you know out
make it easy as well like have
backups of keys so i have my key safe
and then i have the backup key safe yeah
idiotic emergencies that's what i call
it i'll pay you cleaners extra to get
them to be to be oh yeah sometimes um so
for i've just now i learned like laundry
was a big problem as well actually yeah
i'm actually going to say laundry might
be
up there up there worse than getting
called at 3am
maybe maybe i've had cleaners in a panic
um not like and they are freaking out so
now i've just got a nice cleaner who
goes in and i pay her five pound extra
she takes the laundry home and then she
brings and she just rotates
and just find a cleaner that you can do
you might be thinking at this point like
oh wow well you've just put me right off
property for life but the thing is
you're working on a full-time job yeah
and you're doing property just sort of
like very part-time on the side yeah but
you're making considerably more money
even though we pay you a good salary
you're still making
thousands and thousands of pounds a
month doing your service accommodation
business yeah which realistically is a
very small yes you've got to oversee it
and be a bit ready yep you could
systemize it fully you then make a
little bit more less profit yeah but
okay what's the best thing about
property then oh my god just um
the financial freedom
i that word i finally get it now like i
i'll just look at my account and it's
just being like ding ding ding i
remember you said something like
what really stuck with me at the rents
of rent revolution was you get one wage
and then you've got all these things
coming out
and then one thing coming in like one
payment a month and i was like that's
so [ __ ] up like that's so true like
that's what i'd never really thought
about like that and now like every
couple of days airbnb airbnb it just
tops me up and i just stay at this
consistent sort of like bank balance
which for me is like i'm real because i
can i kind of spend quite lavishly now
and buy myself nice clothes and i am
about to upgrade my car you'll be
pleased tonight
that's not bad it's not bad but it's
acceptable
and you you take me out tonight's fancy
dinners yeah
when my american express doesn't work
i can treat my boss to a kfc from time
to time but no um i'd say that for me
the money
the money and like
i actually enjoy that i know it's like i
just said it was you know a bad thing
but i enjoy hosting i actually do enjoy
when it's going well i enjoy the
hey like how are you going on because i
always find that my guests are so
pleasant like i've never really have had
obviously the odd thing where they've
lost a key and it's really annoying but
i've never really had a bad guest
because
you know it's a good area
you're a good person goodness attracts
goodness exactly that so what would you
advise someone wanting to get started in
property what the first steps they
should be taking get training just like
just don't make the mistakes because it
will actually affect your mental health
like
it's like
it literally i thought the panic attacks
weren't a real thing i just used to be
like oh they're just dramatic like i
went to drama school i know
they are a real thing and you feel like
you're dying so
and if i'd had the right training and
knew what i was doing and didn't rush
anything and got the right contracts
none of that would have happened yeah so
i mean like it was like a very temporary
it was definitely a temporary thing and
that was the reason for my anxiety and
what the crazy stuff that happened but
if i'd have just got the right training
early doors i would have avoided all
that stress but hey if you're going to
hit the rocks at least be a lighthouse
to others and here you are now super
successful we appreciate you so much i
love you guys i hope you enjoyed the
interview this will be edited by kerry
if you want to connect with kerry um i
will leave her social media details in
the description below also if you want
to come along to the rent to rent
revolution like kerry did it's just a
pound it'll blow your brain we'll teach
you how to do things properly you can
book on i'll leave a link in the
description and i'll also put a link
right here if you want to see more
videos like this with my videographers
you want to hear more stories of me
making my videos financially free check
out amelia's interview right here don't
forget to subscribe and we'll see you
next time
funny
[Music]